tout de suite c'est l'invité de la
matinale marielle de sarnez bonjour bon
je vous êtes députée européenne vice
présidente du modem
alors hier nicolas sarkozy a demandé à
françois bayrou de jouer le jeu de la
primaire et de le soutenir en cas de
victoire que fera françois weill
c'est évidemment tu sarkozy ait craché
c'est à dire complètement saugrenue
complètement déplacé mais on a
l'habitude avec lui françois bayrou l'a
très bien dit hier c'est pas nicolas
sarkozy qui va nous dicter au fond ce
que nous avons à faire nous c'est notre
conscience qui nous le dicte vous savez
françois bayrou dit depuis deux ans
qu'il ne participera pas à la primaire
justement pour ne pas être engagée si
jamais quelqu'un d'autre qu'alain juppé
arrivé en vue de soutenir agir qui se
passe ce qui devient d'ailleurs de plus
en plus improbable que quelqu'un d'autre
alain juppé quand est on sait jamais
parce que c'est pas encore complètement
finie enfin pour le moment les choses se
passent plutôt très bien vous
pronostiquez victoire d'alain juppé en
fait jamais fait avant d'être faits dont
je reste prudente il va falloir que tous
les français qui veulent l'alternance
tous ceux qui veulent qu'on se donne le
maximum de chances pour redresser le
pays bien ils viennent voter pour alain
juppé il se mobilise
c'est ça la grande question c'est celle
de la mobilisation en tous les cas c'est
mon souhait et je le souhaite donc quant
à nicolas sarkozy voilà c'est tout à
fait saugrenues comme je vous le disais
donc effectivement si alain juppé n'est
pas désigné françois bayrou sera bien
candidat à la présidentielle bien sûr
nous avons dit que nous avions nous
pourrions exercé à l'instant présent où
se seraient pas alain juppé notre
liberté entière et pleine et nous ne
manquerons pas le faire nous le disons
depuis longtemps ce matin dans la
république des pyrénées alain juppé dit
que françois bayrou appartient à sa
famille politique vous vous sentez
pleinement appartenir à cette famille
derrière moi je suis pas du même parti
politique qu alain juppé alain juppé le
sait bien d'autres pas du même parti et
en même temps je trouve que vu le
contexte français aujourd'hui vu le
contexte européen vu le contexte
international
nous avons besoin de rassemblement nous
avons besoin de sortir ce pays de la
nasse dans laquelle idées ou je ne sais
pas si on parlera des policiers
enfin on y ajoute tous les problèmes qui
se déroule sous nos yeux
on voit bien qu'on a besoin d'un grand
sursaut républicain démocratique dans le
pays
je pense qu'alain juppé peut être
l'homme de la situation il n'est pas de
notre courant politique mais c'est
d'autant plus respectable au fonds de la
part de françois bayrou de le soutenir
même s'il n'est pas sa famille politique
car nous considérons que oui les
principes et les valeurs qu'ils
défendent nous nous y retrouvons vous
n'êtes pas dans la famille des
républicains
françois bayrou soutient alain juppé
mais il se fait quand même discret il ne
va pas forcément lingerie gagne la
primaire comme comme il le dit depuis
deux ans il le soutiendra pleinement
entièrement et ça il le dit depuis le
premier jour c'est à dire depuis deux
ans le premier jour où à la jpa lancé sa
candidature au temps c'est vrai qu'il se
fait assez discret françois bayrou ya
certains en tout cas dans la famille des
républicains qui reproche à françois
bayrou d'avoir voter françois hollande
on se souvient en 2012
est ce que ça peut être un problème pour
les électeurs d'alain juppé
je crois pas absolument pas vous savez
il va falloir que les républicains
comprennent une chose c'est que si leur
champion a perdu à la dernière élection
présidentielle
c'est pas de la faute de x y z c'est la
faute du champion quand nicolas sarkozy
gagne en 2007 il a fait une très bonne
campagne et c'est normal qinghai moi je
voulais arrêter parce que je soutenais
françois bayrou on a fait un très très
beau score mais enfin s'il avait été un
bon président de la république un bon
président la république nicolas sarkozy
aurait été réélu donc je vous charge des
champions ym
il a un problème nicolas sarkozy c'est
qu'il n'a pas de capacité à reconnaître
et à assumer et à comprendre ses échecs
et caen sont heureux que les parents
n'assument pas en analyse pas échec
c'est très difficile d'avancer
quel est le contenu de l'accord entre
françois bay à eau et alain gelly
l'accord au car le plan des idées même
aucun accord sur le plan des idées nous
sommes compatibles je viens de vous le
dire vous avez par exemple beaucoup
d'attention ce geste très bien la
manière dont alain juppé aborde toute la
question de l'apaisement nécessaire du
rassemblement nécessaire est une forme
de réconciliation pour agir
au service de l'action parce qu'on en a
ras-le-bol depuis 30 ans au fond des
livres des présidents de la république
qui font des promesses ne les tiennent
pas derrière et un pays qui se dégrade
dans la situation se dégrade de plus en
plus je crois qu'avec alain juppé on
pourra avoir cette chance de au fond
sursaut c'est ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure le modem a passablement de
retrouver une sorte d'élan vital
après nous nous aurons nous avons des
différences alain juppé et c'est la vie
et c'est très bien comme ça mais
attendons on va attendre que la primaire
se déroule et après il y aura le modem
associations à l'exercice est ce que le
modem a envie d'être responsable et
l'induction le centre donc le modem bien
sûr à vocation à être dans le pouvoir
participants pour au fonds proposés
imposer ce qu'il est on a besoin d'une
vision plus sociale on a besoin d'une
vision du travail on a besoin d'une
vision sur la question des salariés et
le travail on a besoin d'une vision sur
l'école qui soit juste
il y a beaucoup à faire dans notre pays
beaucoup à reconstruire
nous ne serons pas assez nombreux pour
le faire donc la question c'est que plus
nous serons nombreux pour le faire mieux
ce sera parce que ce sera difficile de
reconstruire mais il faut que vous ayez
représenté aussi philippe vigier a
évoqué donc c'est le président de
conflit d ici à l'assemblée il a évoqué
je le dis pour nos téléspectateurs bien
sûr 70 à 80 députés
vous partez loin mais manger ses
émotions je sais que mettent les choses
d'abord dans le bon ordre
1 la première des choses à faire c'est
ce qu'alain juppé remporte la primaire
ensuite il y aura cinq six mois pour
construire ce contrat de confiance avec
les français
cinq six mois qui vont avant la
présidentielle permettre à alain juppé
de s'adresser à l'ensemble des français
c'est très important ensuite je vais
vous dire une chose pour l'après
présidentielle si on recommence comme
avant avec un président de la république
même si les plus respectables même s'il
est plus estimable mais avec au fond la
même organisation politique la même
manière de faire ou de ne pas faire bien
voilà on recommencera exactement les
mêmes errements avant donc il y aura des
changements apportés donc il y aura des
ruptures pour retrouver de l'efficacité
dans l'action publique c'est absolument
vital pour ça il faudra rassembler large
la république s'il se retrouve soutenu
par 20 25 % des français quelques mois
après son élection il voit évidemment sa
capacité à recréer l'élan vital dans le
pays tout à fait menacer ça l'est parce
que nous souhaitons alors le modem
souhaite travailler avec les
républicains et lui dit souhaite
également travailler avec les
républicains ce que le modem peut
travailler avec lui dès mai le centre le
centre à vocation évidemment à
travailler ensemble à serait mise à
valeur jeu appelée de nos voeux avec
françois bayrou depuis longtemps je leur
disais encore au mois de septembre
depuis longtemps l'ensemble des amis de
lui dit à soutenir alain juppé je vois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le cas la plupart
la région qui est beaucoup de
discussions un vrai dilemme aujourd'hui
par des élus sud beaucoup entre jean
christophe lagarde le font leur beurre
la plupart des élus de l'udi soutiennent
alain juppé j'en suis heureuse j'aurais
même préféré que ça intervienne plus tôt
mais enfin mieux vaut tard que jamais
possible que les électeurs de gauche
vont s'inviter dans cette primaire de la
droite s'inquiète beaucoup nicolas
sarkozy et je pense moi j'ai lu le texte
puisque je pense que je vais aller
acheter un pour lui la charte qui
s'appelle la charte de l'alternance
donc on dit qu'il faut se reconnaître
dans les valeurs républicaines
républicaine de la droite et du centre
voilà donc j'espère que l'ensemble des
candidats l'ayant républicains se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs
républicaines du centre et puis ça
ajoute une phrase très importante c'est
que c'est tous ceux qui souhaitent
l'alternance est à dire le changement au
pouvoir actuel pour assurer garantir le
redressement du pays
écoutez tous les français donc qui
souhaitent l'alternance qui souhaite que
ça change pour permettre le redressement
du pays
moi je les appelle bien sûr à se
mobiliser et à venir voter peu importe
ce qu'ils ont fait dans le passé ou ce
qu'ils feront dire que ça a pu à des
électeurs de françois bayrou avant
d'essayer de raisonner comme si les gens
dans leur famille dans leur discussion
il se disait t'es de droite et du centre
et de gauche côté la plupart des
français sont pas inscrits dans des
partis politiques
ils ont des sensibilités qui peuvent
être quelquefois complexe ils ont pu
faire des votes ils ont pu les invoquer
un jour pour nicolas sarkozy
et puis être déçu par nicolas sarkozy
par alors tous ceux qui sont déçus
aujourd'hui du gouvernement actuel au
fond et tous ceux qui veulent surtout
moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est le
positif
tous ceux qui veulent reconstruire le
pays reconstruit à la france retrouver
un élan pour le pays et pour la france
en europe et donc pour l'europe
tout cela il faut qu'ils viennent voter
et vous pensez que nicolas sarkozy
respectera lui la règle de la primaire
si toutefois elle trouve qu'il ya trop
d'électeurs de gauche qui sont allés
voter
je n'en doute pas je n'en doute pas il
l'a dit on va parler de l'ukraine ya les
accords de minsk qui sont dans l'impasse
l'élargissement la mission des
observateurs de l'osce et a été décidé
hier est ce que vous pensez qu'elle peut
régler le problème de l'ukraine
je pense que le reggae problèmes de
l'ukraine passera par nos relations avec
la russie
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est à dire
passera par un accord à un moment donné
avec petit donc c'est très compliqué
parce qu'il faut en même temps avoir une
stratégie où on est capable de maintenir
des sanctions ou même peut-être d'en
promettre d'autres et en même temps
dialoguer et se parler parce qu'on
n'arrivera pas à sortir des problèmes
dans lesquels nous sommes
vous parlez de l'ukraine on pourrait
parler de la syrie dans une seconde et
par ailleurs il faudra bien aussi que en
ukraine on est une réflexion sur une
organisation de l'ukraine on va dire
plus fédéral je pense que c'est comme ça
qu'on pourra trouver une issue favorable
on va écouter nicolas dupont aignan qui
s'est exprimé ce matin sur les relations
entre la france et la russie et vous
réagissez
ceux qui ont tué des français sur notre
sol c'est l'état islamique et je
préfèrerais voir la france combat
davantage l'état islamique avec l'aide
de la russie a eu avec l'aide d'assad
parce que j'en ai assez de cette
hypocrisie on ne combat pas ceux qui ont
tué des français sur notre sol la russie
à protéger les chrétiens d'orient la
russie lutte contre l'état islamique et
nous combattons la russie avouez que on
marche sur la tête
il faut dialoguer mais on remarquera que
nicolas dupont-aignan dans ce qu'il dit
oublie de dire que la russie bombe avant
ce moment les populations rebelles à la
population civile
alaibe donc ça aurait été complet de
l'ajouter cedej bien sûr bien sûr nous
sommes tous d'accord là-dessus
d'ailleurs la france participe à la
coalition comprenait j'espère qu'on va
avoir des avancées importantes sur
mossoul
en même temps ne réglera pas la question
du conflit au fond sans mettre autour de
la table tous les acteurs régionaux 1
essentiellement turquie l'arabie
saoudite iran bien sûr et puis la russie
pour trouver des issues et préservé au
fond les intérêts vitaux des uns et des
autres moi ce qui me chagrine dans tout
ça c'est que poutine il a une stratégie
elle est claire on voit un il veut
avancer avancer avancer avancer ses
pions en syrie avant même de discuter
d'un vrai accord de paix l'europe n'a
pas stratégie voilà et c'est ça qui me
chagrine on a besoin de parler ni même
voie mais on ne parle pas d'une même
voix bien évidemment mais c'est vital
jeudi on entend les états unis un peu on
entend et on voit la russie son action
beaucoup ce qu'on entend pas c'est
l'union européenne
or moi je suis une européenne convaincue
je suis persuadé que pour l'équilibré du
monde
on a besoin d'une puissance européenne
forte et c'est pourquoi nous aurons
besoin d'un président de la république
qui relancera l'europe ça va passer à
comme ça tout seul facilement alors dans
les mois qui viennent là il faut
absolument que l'ensemble des dirigeants
européens parlent d'une seule voix sur
les stratégies à avoir soit en ukraine
soit en syrie oui bien sûr fermeté avec
la russie bien avec menace de son
meilleur en même temps il est obligé de
parler à la russie ne pas se parler il
fallait recevoir par exemple la dîmière
poutine il ya huit jours je pense qu'il
fallait le recevoir tout en alliant lui
car la gamme et lui parler les yeux dans
les yeux dans le bureau à l'elysée je
n'ai pas aimé la façon dont la séquence
a été gérée à la vérité vous trouvez que
la france ne parle pas assez n'est pas
assez n'a pas une voix qui porte à c'est
pourtant la france participe à la
coalition internationale
il ya le charles de gaulle qui est quand
même positionné dans la région sur glace
oui n'est pas quand même totalement
transparent dans cette sale guerre non
mais vous voyez bien que si on parle
d'abord il faudrait qu'on parle et qu'on
soit cohérent on l'a pas toujours été
notamment sur la question sur la
question syrienne et ensuite vous voyez
bien que quand la france parle même tout
seul ça ne suffit pas donc il faut que
l'europe se décide à avoir une politique
une politique étrangère une politique de
défense
si on n'en profite pas en ce moment pour
mettre en oeuvre une ambition de défense
européenne
on ne fera jamais on voit bien que les
menaces et sont de plus en plus lourdes
de plus en plus forte que les conflits
sont à nos portes en parler de l'ukraine
tout à l'heure on parle de la syrie ce
est à nos portes avec toutes les
implications de sa une guerre civile
terrible des guerres civiles terrible en
syrie une crise maintenu de 10 millions
de syriens qui sont dans un état de
crise humanitaire terrible déplacer
manque d'alimentation plus toute la
question des migrants et des réfugiés
parce que bien évidemment
près de 5 millions réfugiés dans les
pays voisins avec des impacts nous
l'avons vu sur sur l'europe
donc bien sûr que l'europe doit enfin se
décider à exister et à peser
on va parler de la colère des policiers
aujourd'hui l'intersyndicale appelle à
manifester tous les mardis devant le
palais de justice
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a bien géré la situation
françois hollande doit recevoir la les
syndicats de police ont démissionné
c'est d'abord et c'est très important de
comprendre ce qui se passe je crois
qu'effectivement on a le sentiment les
policiers sur le terrain ont le
sentiment qu'ils sont un peu seul genre
je les entendais parler sont des pions
ils ont le sentiment d'une déconnexion
avec leur hiérarchie beaucoup de
difficultés matérielles beaucoup de
difficultés d'organisation pas de retour
d'expérience sur ce qui se fait ici ou
là comme il ya dans d'autres pays on a
le sentiment qu'on a un vrai problème
d'organisation
ça repose aussi sur une chose c'est que
nicolas sarkozy avait supprimé la police
de proximité et que ça c'était une
erreur stratégique je pendrai la
rétablir majeur mais c'est vital de la
rétablir
vous pouvez pas avoir dans des cités
difficiles ou des endroits difficiles
des politiques qui en permanence
viennent de l'extérieur il faut avoir à
l'intérieur des policiers qui
connaissent leurs terrains qui sont
connus des habitants et ceci est
effectivement de nature à créer d
apaisement et à régler les problèmes qui
sont terribles et que nous avons vu
encore il ya quelques jours et la
semaine dernière particulièrement que ce
jeune policier qui est encore à
l'hôpital très gravement atteints jouer
mais on a un problème d'organisation on
a un problème de soutien moral
psychologique financier à la police et
en même temps il faut que les policiers
dans les jours qui viennent
agissent comme fo ce qu'ils sont
responsables de l'ordre public c'est
très important arrêter les
manifestations c'est très important
qu'il y ait une prise de conscience de
quelque chose qui plus qu'un malaise
je crois vraiment qu'ils aient une
dégradation continue comprenez vous leur
vision sur les comprendre l'exaspération
dégradation continue de leurs conditions
de travail
ceci concerne toute la nation il faut
que les pouvoirs publics prennent la
mesure de l'ampleur de ce que les
policiers sont en train de leur dire est
qu'ils se parlent
on va écouter quand même christian
estrosi qui défend lui le bilan de
nicolas sarkozy
était vous rendez compte que monsieur
cazeneuve a porté plainte contre une
policière municipale et adresse le plus
profond mépris aux revendications des
policiers qui sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui lité je regarde les projets
et je suis le meilleur et je vois que le
seul qui prend des engagements très
forts à mettre en oeuvre à court terme
c'est aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy c'est
ce qui m'incite à m'engager à ses côtés
c'est mieux placé pour ce dossier n'ont
cessé ces déplacés donc on répondre
canard cazenove il a eu un mot voilà
qu'il n'aurait pas dû avoir il a eu une
maladresse terrible mais pour le reste
c'est un homme tout à fait estimable
je dirais qui est tout à fait
respectable et donc mettre en cause les
personnes à un moment où au contraire la
nation tout entière devra essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe chez ces
policiers parce qu'au fond les policiers
sont là pour nous pour le peuple
français
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
les entendre avoir un plan peut-être de
réorganisation de soutien matériel
financier
bref tout ce qu'il faut et tout ce qui
est attendu sur le terrain depuis trop
longtemps
tout ceci ne date pas d'hier et
d'avant-hier bien évidemment les
événements attentats terrorisme ont mis
une charge de travail tout à fait
supplémentaires sur les policiers mais
c'est pas par la manière dont prend la
question dont estrosi prend la question
qu'on va y arriver il faut qu'on soit
tous responsables
merci marielle de sarnez d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes députée européenne et
vice-présidente du modem très bonne
journée à vous merci d'être passé par le
plateau de politique matin